بيداوا مركز
الكارثة الإنسانية في الصومال ومصدر
نقود جاهزة لإرهابيي الشباب
أولاً وقبل كل شيء نحتاج إلى التحدث إلى الرجل
الذي يعرف أكثر عن
التمويل حسنًا ، حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
ضباط المخابرات الوطنية الصومالية يأخذوننا
في السر.  سجن الشباب الذي تم
أسره قبل أيام قليلة ، كان هذا
المقاتل السابق من حركة الشباب على خط المواجهة
في جمع التبرعات المالية حيث جمع
آلاف الدولارات من رسوم الطرق التي تم أخذ الكثير منها
من الشاحنات التي تقدم الطعام
للاجئين ، إنها دائرة من الاستغلال
وقع ضحايا فيها.  هناك
مئات الآلاف من هؤلاء الذين
يتلقون أموالاً من المانحين الأجانب ،
هذا هو مخيم بودين للاجئين ، حيث يوجد
تدفق مستمر للاجئين يأتون إلى هنا
كل يوم ، ومن المستحيل الوصول إليه
بدون مرافقة من الاتحاد
الأفريقي والأشخاص الذين يفرون إلى هنا
يفرون من الجفاف وهم يفرون من
الصراع وبالطبع هاتان المجموعتان هما
المربحتان جدًا لمجموعات مثل الشباب
كانت عائلة فاطمة من أمراء الحرب تمتلك عشرات
الماعز وسبع أبقار
دفعها الجفاف والصراع إلى النزول إلى الطريق
، والآن ليس لديها سوى الفقر
المدقع وما زالت مصدر دخل
لحركة الشباب مائتان وسبعون
ألف لاجئ يعيشون الآن في بيداوا و
يأتي المزيد كل يوم وهذا هو المكان الذي
تربح فيه الجماعة الإرهابية الآن
وكيلًا للحكومة ، كان هذا الرجل
جابيًا لضرائب الشباب لمدة ثماني سنوات.
التجار يجلبون الطعام للبيع
للاجئين يدفعون إلى الشباب للوصول إلى بيداوا
ويفرضون عليهم ضرائب هناك أيضًا وإذا كانوا  لا
تدفع مقابل تشغيل الطابور ، أخبرني
أن جماعة الشباب جنت حوالي 3 دولارات على كل كيس
أرز يتم تسليمه إلى بيدوة ،
لذا فإن هذا لا ينجح ، فأنت تقول إنه
لا يعمل ، ولا تزال الأمم المتحدة
تدفع الضرائب المطلقة لنا بشكل غير مباشر  على حد سواء
من أجل حواجز الطرق
بالباب كان في مركز المجاعات التي من صنع الإنسان
التي قتلت 300000 في عام 1992
ربع مليون في عام 2012 وتلك
التي وجهها أحد المساعدين العام الماضي
لتجنب سرقة الإمدادات  تحولت N
إلى التحويل المباشر نقدًا إلى اللاجئين
في العام الماضي ، مما أدى إلى تحويل
المسؤولية عن نقل الطعام إلى
التجار ، لكن جماعة الشباب استمرت
في جني الأرباح ، ويمكن القول إن هناك
بالفعل حافزًا لمنزل بابك
لتركيز الناس في بيدوا
على توصيل المساعدات هناك و  فقط
كشط ثلاثة دولارات من حقيبة أعتقد
أن هذا ربما يكون صحيحًا والشيء هو
كيف تخفف وتدير هذا
النوع من المشاكل أعني وما هو
البديل الذي تقدر الأمم المتحدة أن
حاجزًا واحدًا من الشباب على طول
طريق مقديشو إلى بيدوا  يولد خمسة
آلاف دولار يوميًا للجماعة الإرهابية
، وأصبحت طرق البلاد
مصدر إمداد الشباب المالي بالدم
، وكان اثنان وعشرون ألف جندي أفريقي
يقاتلون الإرهابيين ، لكن من
المقرر أن ينسحبوا في غضون عامين إذا
قللنا ذلك سيؤثر على  العمليات العامة بشكل
سلبي ستترك
فراغ يمكن أن تدخله الشباب
بالتأكيد سيترك زر
وفراغ.  د ترك الشباب أكثر
قدرة على استغلال اللاجئين سام كيلي سي إن إن
بحلول الظلام